animal photos colors this is then minute
peper shoot cardozo knife and deep
learning means that we are working with
neurlet works that contain many inner
layer
and knees runs in each player combine
information from delay or before
the deeper wego in this networks de
marilla brad the tears will  join to sea
level loket and i sample for instance
disappeared your network to recognize
images of human feces first with
cms-detector
and is it combination of ages object
parts will emerge in the neck slayer and in
the reader layers
combination of object parts create
object models
meow texture syntus is about creating
lots of new images base om an input
texture and these new images have to
resemble
met met copy the input previous work and
you all texts for syntus is focused on
get that friend features in archives
layer
who leads to the once  before and after
it the show is that pico's now runs in
congo lotion on your network drops in it
so in other words recipes field day canon loket
e  n input texture edwin skill
so fears and civil also here you see that
with previews technically
trying to create mosques details in the
synthesize texture is going to lead to
run der poll results
so 0 with there is a by changing the input
and the output or the  network to be
losing process these images
and die friend skills die ski jacket range
from corsair to final version of de c
managers some simple enough
write this simple idea makes all the
difference
here you can see the input texture and
here is that output
as you  can see it has the [ __ ] cares with
he them very similar properties to the
input and the free zoo min to both of
these images
who can you see this form is able to
create beautiful high frequency details
is wel wow this is sam wiel i realy
crisp output
nou dit has to be emphasized that this
means that the statistical properties of
the original image
arbi mikt really well why doesn't mean i
is that this takes into consideration doen
meaning of these images just  have loket
de synthesize bubbles
order flowers here the stats
properties of the synthesize textures may
be correct with the semantic meaning of the
input is with capture duel in the future
work it would be superuse for
tristan favoring him greater
understanding of the structure and  the
symmetry is of the input images into
consideration the source code is
available under the permissions mit
license
zo dan will battles crazy expert mens
evhc van join this episode and you think
the series provides your video
entertainment please consider supporting
the front page you want and payments  en
crypto currency is like bitcoin
criterium also supported and herbin
massively successful
i'm really auto's words thank you so
much
the slides er available in the video
discription exact chinian folio generous
support na see you next time
[Music]
yes